الياس كرام ينضم الينا من جنوب عسقلان
وربما الجانب الاسرائيلي بدا يوضح بعض
النقاط فيما يتعلق بالاثار التي
نتجت عن الاستهداف والصواريخ التي تم
اطلاقها من قطاع غزه
وربما اصابت بعض المناطق داخل اسرائيل
نعم بالفعل والساعات الاخيره حملت معها
مزيدا من القذائف الصاروخيه التي وجهت صوب
المجمع السكاني المعروف باشكول في غلاف
غزه والذي يضم عددا كبيرا من المستوطنات
والبلدات الاسرائيليه في تلك المنطقه كان
هنالك سقوط لقذيفتين صاروخيتين في احدى
البلدات الاسرائيليه هناك مما نجم عن ذلك
اضرار ماديه في احد المنازل دون ان يبلغ
عن وقوع اصابات في صفوف الاسرائيليين
استهدافات متتاليه كانت ايضا لمنطقه كرم
ابو سالم عند طلاقي الحدود الاسرائيليه
الفلسطينيه المصريه في جنوب قطاع غزه لكن
واضح بان الساعات الاخيره ايضا حملت معها
تحديدا هنا في المنطقه الشماليه في منطقه
ازديروت وجنوب عسقلان هدوءا نسبيا حيث
كثافه الصواريخ التي وجهت من جانب
المقاومه الفلسطينيه مقارنه مع يوم امس
حيث كانت هذه المنطقه
تعرضت لوابل شديد من القذائف والصواريخ
التي اطلقتها المقاومه الفلسطينيه باتجاه
جنوب عسقلان وباتجاه نتيفا عصرا وزكيم
وكرميه وناح العوز وازديروت وكانت اوقعت
بالفعل اصابات مباشره في عدد من المباني
لعل الاضرار الجسيمه كانت في احد الاحياء
السكنيه في مدينه عسقلان حيث نجم عن نجمه
اضرار كبيره عن سقوط صاروخ في قلبه حي
ماهول بالاسرائيليين وكانت هنالك اضرار
جسيمه في المباني وفي السيارات في داخل
هذا الحي فيما يبدو ان القبه الحديديه
عجزت عن
اعتراض هذا الصاروخ كما عجزت عن اعتراض
صواريخ اخرى هي كانت سببت اضرارا جسيمه في
بعض البلدات المتاخمه للحدود مع قطاع غزه
في منطقه اشكول وتحديدا في ازديرات التي
اصيب فيها ثلاثه منازل الاسعاف الاسرائيلي
يقول بانه تعامل منذ بدايه هذا التصعيد مع
اثنتين وثلاثين اصابه نصفها كانت حالات
هلاك كما قال ونصفها الاخر كان ناجما عن
اصابات للاسرائيليين بكسور او ردود او
خدوش وهم يهربون باتجاه الملاجئ للسيما
وان المده الزمنيه
المطلوبه لبلوغ الملاجئ في هذه المناطق
الحدوديه لا تتعدى بضعه ثواني فقط وحالات
الهلع كانت ناجمه بالفعل عن الانفجارات
الشديده التي كانت تشهدها المنطقه
الشماليه
مع قطاع غزه تحديدا هنا في منطقه زكيم وفي
منطقه كرميه ونتيف عسره حيث ان
القذائف التي اطلقتها المقاومه الفلسطينيه
باتجاهات المتعدده وفي طبقات الجو
المختلفه اربكت منظومه القبه الحديديه
التي كانت تقوم بعمليات اعتراض يعني
تقريبا عشوائيه وعلى مقربه من سطح الارض
وعلى مقربه من اسطح المنازل الاسرائيليه
في هذه البلدات مما نجم عن ذلك بطبيعه
الحال اضرار ماديه وكذلك حالات هلع في
صفوف الاسرائيليين الذين نقلوا الى مستشفى
برزيلاي في عسقلان المستشفى الاقرب لهذه
المنطقه الجيش الاسرائيلي تحدث في الساعه
الاخيره بان سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي استهدف
موقعا استطلاعيا يستخدم لاطلاق قذائف
القذائف المدفعيه المضاده للدروع في قطاع
غزه
واستهدف ايضا موقعا اخر يستخدم لاطلاق
قذائف الهاون باتجاهي المناطق العسكريه
الاسرائيليه المتاخمه للحدود وكذلك
البلدات الاسرائيليه القريبه والملاصقه
للحدود مع قطاع غزه وقد نشر تصويرا لهذه
الاستهدافات واضح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يصب جهوده الان او يركز جهوده الان في
محاوله لاستيراد هذه الخلايا التي تعمل
كما يبدو على مقربه من السياج الامني في
قطاع غزه في محاوله لتسديد ضربات للمواقع
العسكريه الاسرائيليه ذلك ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي كما اشرت يستهدف مواقع
الرصد ومواقع الاستطلاع التي تستخدم
لتوجيه الضربات الصاروخيه بقذائف الكورنيت
القذائف الموجهه وبالتالي يبدو ان هنالك
خشيه لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي من ان خلايا
تعمل بكثافه في تلك المنطقه على
ايقاعي ربما اصابات مباشره في صفوف الجنود
الاسرائيليين الذين ينشطون ويعملون في تلك
المنطقه الحدوديه سنعود اليك مجددا بطبيعه
الحال من جنوب عسقلان لاسلام شكرا جزيلا
لك على كل هذه